il y a trois ans cette jeune femme avait
été opéré d'une crise tech tommy depuis
elle est soumise à un rythme d'au moins
deux contrôles post opératoires par an
sauf que pour consulter un spécialiste
c'est la croix et la bannière jaune
aujourd'hui de pouvoir trouver un rendez
vous est ce que suivie par un praticien
spécialiste temps par là la durée des
rendez vous dans mon cas en gynécologie
aujourd'hui j'ai attendu un an
[Musique]
des rendez vous difficile à obtenir des
salles d'attentes qui ne désemplissent
pas comment expliquer les difficultés à
se faire ausculter par certains
praticiens
la plupart des praticiens actuellement
sur une activité libérale sans train de
partir à la retraite ceux qui sont
présents sont encore moins nombreux que
ceux qui sont en train de partir à la
retraite et donc de ce fait on ne peut
pas tout seul assumer les consultations
d'une population de l'environnement
casse en cassant cette arme il habite en
gynéco opthalmo autorise nous des
spécialités difficile à côtoyer des
spécialistes devenu presque inaccessible
martinique parce qu'il y en a peu
d'après ce chirurgien rencontre de
consultation sur le plan médical la
martinique n'est pas un pays très
attractifs et les gens vont les gens et
font dans les villes pénurie de
praticiens également dans les hôpitaux
publics service pédiatrie du chu où les
25 lits du service sont pratiquement
tous occupés à cause d'une épidémie
semble coccolithes ici on espère
qu'aucune complication de va nécessiter
l'intervention de certaines spécialités
notre rôle est particulièrement affectée
dans le domaine de
de la pédiatrie mais globalement nous
sommes concernés par la pénurie médicale
pour l'ensemble des spécialités qui
interviennent au sein du pôle pédiatrie
gynécologie obstétrique de moins en
moins de médecins une densité médicale
la plus faible après la guyane
deux cent soixante pour cent mille
habitants toutes spécialités confondues
les décideurs d'après ce patron de
cliniques ont laissé faire les décideurs
politiques de nous ne s'en sont pas
occupés et continueront ils ont continué
à dire que neil non il ya suffisamment
de médecins que la densité médicale est
parfait ce n'est que cette année que la
rs martinique dit clairement et écrit
que oui un problème démographie médicale
là on est dans le creux de la vague
donc pour pouvoir
corrigé mais il faut fabriquer des
médecins la restriction il ya une
quarantaine d'années du nombre de
praticiens destinées à diminuer le
nombre de prescripteurs est un échec
aujourd'hui les jeunes médecins qui
sortent de la pac sont attirés par des
régions plus attractive entre temps la
martinique atteint des taux de rocco qui
sont très bas parce que l'offre de soins
reste limitée